- [Voiceover] In this
video we're gonna introduce
a couple of words to help talk about the
relationship between sines and cosines,
or different sinusoids that
have the same frequency,
but a different timing relationship.
So, what I've shown here,
is a plot of a cosine,
and a sine wave.
And the axis here is in theta,
in the angle, the radian angle
of the cosine or sine.
Now I can label these, the pi over two
represents a 90 degrees change.
Pi is 180,
degrees.
This is 270 degrees.
And this is 360 degrees.
Those are two equivalent,
scales for the angle, the angle axis,
in degrees or in radians.
Now, one thing we notice
here is that sine and cosine,
they look the same,
but they don't overlap.
If I change this to a time,
If I change this to a time, axis,
what I can say is
the cosine wave reaches its
peak at time equals zero,
and the sine peak, the sine wave,
reaches its peak at a later time,
this is increasing time going this way.
So, the sine is delayed
compared to the cosine.
The peak here is delayed here.
If I go down and look at these two peaks,
we see the same relationship.
This sine peak in orange,
is behind, is delayed, from
the cosine.
So when we have this timing relationship
between two periodic waves,
what we say is, in this case,
we say that the cosine,
leads,
the sine wave.
And the amount of lead
is the difference between
these two points,
and we can say the lead is
270 minus 180, in this
case, it'd be 90 degrees.
So we say that cosine, leads
sine
by 90 degrees.
Now I can take exactly the
opposite point of view.
If I actually measure where
the sine is relative to cosine,
I say it's behind, then
we would say it lags.
So the phrase we hear would be
sine lags cosine
by 90 degrees.
So that's the term lead and
lag, that's what those mean.
Now these terms apply,
this idea of a delay,
this only applies when these
frequencies are the same.
If the frequencies are different,
the relationship between
the two wave functions
changes all the time.
So, we use the word lead and lag when we
know that the two signals
we are talking about
are exactly the same frequency.
One thing I want to be able to do
is express sines and cosines
in terms of each other.
So, if I have a sine wave,
could I actually express this orange curve
as a cosine wave?
How would a do that?
So what I've noticed,
if I look at the value of sine right here,
and this is sine at 90 degrees,
or sine at pi over two,
if I look at this value here,
what I notice is that,
this has the same value,
which is the peak of one.
Cosine has the same
value, the peak of one,
but 90 degrees earlier, 90 degrees before,
because it's a leading function.
So this suggests a conversion factor.
Any time I pick out a value of the sine,
if I look back 90 degrees,
I'll see the same value for cosine.
So I can write something like this,
I can say that sine of theta
equals the cosine of theta,
minus 90 degrees.
If I go out to some value,
let's say there on the sine curve,
and if I back up 90 degrees,
like that, I'll read the same
value on the cosine curve,
so these two functions will
give me the same number.
So I can write this
identity in reverse also.
If I have a cosine, if I'm riding along
on this cosine wave,
what I notice is, if
let's say I'm right here,
I'll notice I have my peak value here,
and if I added, if I went later in time,
or if I added 90 degrees,
I would have the same value
on that orange sine curve.
So if I look here, on cosine,
if I want to know what that is,
in terms of a sine function,
if I add 90 degrees to the argument,
the sine function will
give me the same value.
So what that says, is cosine theta,
equals sine of theta, plus 90.
So these are two
identities, we can use this
to convert a something
expressed as a sine,
into a cosine, or vice versa.
Now I want to show you
two more identities,
that are actually pretty useful.
And here what I have is, I
sketched on in dash lines
the negative of the orange curve,
so this is a negative sine wave.
You can see it the opposite
of the original sine wave we had.
So now I have the case
here where the cosine
is trailing, or lagging,
the negative sine.
Right, it comes later
in time, right there.
So cosine lags negative sine.
And what I'll do is, I'll write
the same sort of identities here,
but in terms of this negative sine,
and those come out like this.
Cosine of theta,
equals minus sine,
so that's the dashed one,
of theta, minus 90 degrees.
So what that means, if I want
to know the value of cosine,
and I can flip that around the same way,
and I can say that
negative sine
of theta
equals cosine
of theta plus 90.
That's the same identity but in reverse.
If I want to know the
value of negative sine,
I just take that argument,
I add it, I advance it by 90 degrees,
and take the cosine,
it'll have the same value.
So, this identity
and,
this identity,
are pretty useful to have around.
This one allows us to convert
sines and cosines together.
This pair here is useful for
moving minus sines around.
So that's what I wanted
to say about lead and lag.
These are sort of slang or jargon,
the nicknames of the relationship between
two different wave forms
of the same frequency
but different phase timing,
different phase delay.
And then we worked out
some, some identities
that are kind of useful to have around,
to be able to convert these two wave forms
from one to the other and back.